questa mattina dovevo fare il
trattenimento in due sì perché dico
poverino ha montato fino a tardissimo
possiamo dire una cosa veramente col
cuore
bravo enrico scriviamolo bravo enrico
perché si sta facendo un mazzo fan le
note quindi è certo punto mi si è
stretto il cuore ieri ho detto ti prego
tu dormi pensiamo a tutto quanto io
gianmarco questo logo non esisterebbe
senza esisterebbe senza eri così
malgioglio sta entrando anche dentro di
me ma giugno
il villaggio perché del mondo la gioia
forse guardando ha capito che questa
erba direi che qualche per in testa
celarsi però nei commenti ai video
precedenti ne hanno detto che sta
facendo una muffa e muffa questa e non è
normale che tiri fuori sto verde ma
minuta vendita ma che costo sta pagando
secondo me un costo troppo alto
rispetto poi al trattamento che sta
ottenendo comunque stiamo parlando
comunque di un mezzo cioè di homer
simpson a livello di capelli c'è quindi
secondo te sta crescendo ma sta
crescendo bene
bell'idea oppure questo concime era
mettere pochissimo da questa è acqua
a queste ponte nella mia sono pronto ad
altri parenti domani sarà nato lo
vedremo un pochino come va anche perché
poi tra un po partiamo per la sicilia
cioè manca di che ce lo possiamo portato
si è detto che farebbero a cosa vi
trovate di fronte a un proprietario
terriero me è successa cosa meravigliosa
treedom non so se conoscete che quel
sito nel quale puoi regalare alberi kg
pianta non le puoi seguire mi ha
regalato centro alberi quindi adesso
devo creato una foresta che si chiama
winwood c'è guarda che bello adesso ti
dovremmo chiamare tipo lordo uil lorde
all'ora intatto o 99 alberi ne vorrei
regalare uno ha avocato scannerini scale
risi che deve accettarlo ma ne abbiamo
già regalato una stretta dell'umore
ferone del alber bob che è l'albero che
abbiamo regalato a beatrice che avete
visto sulla nostra sull eterno della
cover video della
birra e la soprano miniamo bob sì è vero
se sembrava facile che abbiamo sempre
bob quindi un albergo trovare per tutti
quanti i componenti della famiglia di
non velino mi vorrei mettere la foto del
profilo vedi che c'è lui che è
carinissimo molto carino se innanzitutto
al norm welod sé perché non scarti
questo è da parte loro subito che ci sia
all'albero nove ragazzi non sono dei
geni
guarda che carino piante altro albero se
volete regalare un albero pure voi qua
mi dicono che c'è la possibilità di
avere il 15 per cento di sconto
utilizzando una volta questo codici
nochè we would che il nome della nostra
foresta la uil e foreste questo fino al
31 dicembre detto ciò torniamo un attimo
alla mia propria proprietà di noi prima
o poi dovremo andare nella bufera
mammamia allora io qui vedo che abbiamo
un botto di alberi iniziamo a regalargli
che dici in partita la famiglia partiamo
la famiglia voi vorreste far parte della
uil with forest come possiamo fare tipo
se qualcuno vuole far parte nel welfare
sta che se volete regalarli a qualcuno
che avete la possibilità di farlo ma se
volete far parte della mia foresta io
potrete creare un albero almeno quelli
che lanciano quanti ne vuoi lega
dall'altro pubblico al 100 intanto dire
50 no forse è una famiglia numerosa
diamo 30 32 come mi anni gli anni di
grace gallini chris come non regaliamo
gli anni di cristo in alberi e 33 alberi
scegliamo il 33 nomi più simpatici che
ci mettono nei commenti se anche molto
carino dei lumi simpatici per il
problema proprio albero oppure pagare se
nelle storie su instagram
in un post su instagram in un modo che è
più facile poter chiedere poi quali sono
le vostre mail e perché lo sa per le
nostre menti poterli inviare il regalo
non commentate mai qua sotto mettendo
una
tra mail mai per ragazzi che state
aspettando parcheggia e della uil
woodman o creando una specie di loghino
da inserire al posto e la foto a questa
qui che sembra quasi una spilla quindi
con dei riflessi dorati un pochino come
quelli che abbiamo nel biglietto di
auguri che vogliamo fare faccio vedere
in questo qui alla fine il biglietto
molto bello ognuno di noi a questa
spilla vede ogni anno e ce l'ha come
abbiamo fatto bellissima sì l'ho
cambiato dove ognuno di noi ha la spilla
della uil hus farei questa spilletta
solo che mettere che ne so dei
rampicanti dell'header e che gli stanno
attorno i partecipanti però sono lor
winwood e beatrice renzo alberto rodio
vorrei dire la prima cosa che mi è
sembrata che cosa un testicolo
ma è gianmarco ma che stai dicendo se no
anche un boccino d'oro un po colorata
cioè un po cosa veloso ai rischi tutto
il pericolo sembra più una palla adesso
però come fatta ma del non puoi dirlo
con che stanno notando che i tuoi alberi
sono sparsi tra il kenya e il camerun
ok quindi quindi in africa se il primo a
quando lo regalo dai lo regalerà io
londra oggi sono tutti piantati questi
100 alberi simas ovviamente devono
crescere
quanto sarà ora un albero 3 cm tu mi sei
ricominciando a chiedere tutto ciò io
sono lordo il web
basta coi è finito finito c'è la foresta
di will buller già prospera visto in
difficoltà sei con me o traditori non
adesso sembra non sicuramente la sacca
maschile basta non so nemmeno vedendo
come volevo vogliono che il tuo albero
non è il logo
mi raccomando ragazzi non commentate con
loreto albero non il tuo stupido logo e
dopo un'ora abbiamo fatto questa cosa
che in realtà poteva essere fatta molto
più semplicemente però è carina
ci piace non è centrata sul timone non è
centrata pastello io possa uccidere una
cosa più semplice non mi piace ma è
carino è brutto non è brutto ci hai
messo solo un'ora purtroppo dai
regaliamo le arti l'oreal no che ti
regalo che a meri abbiamo a disposizione
un sacco di avvocato a delle mangrovie
jam android già mangano il tuo hard
regia mandro già mano però l'albero di
jean pazzo o riti camera già manico e
non me ne frega niente più bello per
finaco race far sapere la latitudine la
longitudine del mio albero che ve li
vado a trovarlo lapini ha già se lo è
auto regalato lavora 96 guarda dove sei
non basa si trovi il quirinale che si è
attaccato al mare
guarda vicino anche a questa specie di
bahia interna ma allora ve la faccio un
viaggetto viola vengo anch'io
marcando un caffè beh se poi tu lo
sfrutti nella notte ha bisogno avrà
bisogno del caffè si e dalla bocca mi
regalo un caffè e come lo chiamiamo un
caffè caffè il cappello non è male sono
un investimento sul futuro di tuo
fratello della simpatica henry co2 e
ricci o due e riccio due si mandiamo gli
altri e voglio regalare una gianluigi
del mare gianlivio gli regaliamo un
caffè anche a lui giallo livio già
l'ulivo jean livo java senti collegato
mail ti sto regalando un albero un
albero si praticamente ci hanno regalato
una foresta e quindi a stava regalando
ai nostri parenti tra l'altro di natale
un albero o regalato un albero di caffè
al perfetto lucchetto se vuoi ti diamo
latitudine longitudine e poi andare in
kenya dove in kenya è in kenya ok ok a
capri nella e bisogna regalare a
gabriele un albero un caffè cacao che
aprì ed era perché abbiamo dati abi lab
regaterà gabriele clinico si è fatto
kate è arrivato un albero comunque vabbè
aprire la mail e febbre ma così capisci
ragazzi e li farò più avanti tutti gli
altri è perché volete sapere chi farebbe
vorrebbe ottenere un albero e far parte
della uil forest
adesso possiamo andare a mangiare già il
minibreak e ci facciamo un giro magari
per partorire o mantenere se ci stanno
dei regali e io pure devo fà regalo di
battesimo al mio figlio tu sei intero un
padrino lo diventerò papà
e neanche mica padrino siamo in macchina
però per andare a portarono aveva deciso
di usare l'iphone per bloccare in modo
anche da passare né romito si meno
osservati perché abbiamo comunque una
videocamera abbastanza appariscente però
tipo di coprire di pensare ai regali di
[Musica]
carboidrati carboidrati la cosa bella
perché gioco porte di roma e che
fondamentalmente l'unico modo per
trovarlo specialmente in questo periodo
dell'anno è lanciarsi dalla macchina sia
un se guidatore e coprire con il tuo
corpo
la zona interessata in questo modo
dovresti non aver problemi
gianmarco allora entriamo andiamo a
mangiare io sono come faccio a passare
da qui se abbiamo delle palle
nelle palle luminose per questo natale
ci piaccia una volta giornata è tutta a
sfondo di ballo ma vero è vero e tutto
un po palle
comunque oddio decorazioni semplici e
delicate vedo spacca porta a noi
il richiamo della mela è un uomo non è
babbo natale perché non lo so perché è
magro e babbo natale se avesse tipo
preso le gambe di naomi campbell che
carino lui invece enrico ferri gianni io
una domanda per terra e dico che fine ha
fatto è morto nessuno lo ha sentito oggi
no e non si è fatto sentire minimamente
sono preoccupato yuri chechi
schiaccianoci
vai di carini
mamma mia si e carboidrati per me
stanno facendo una considerazione quanti
chili per non dire tonnellate di cibo a
facciamo nella vita attraverso antichi
li mangiamo di rho banalità senza
quantità in una vita di un media di 70
anni
secondo me una tonnellata la cache come
di più molto di più
benissimo dire questo questi sono punti
soldi che ha speso tutto il cibo che
mangiato chiusa la merda che cacava
ecco questo interrogativo che vi
lasciamo perderà 5 g mia mamma mia come
noto di gianmarco si muove
sì sicuramente non è babbo natale quello
di questa ragione tu
ma quando spicci hanno fatto anch'io a
tutto questo cosa viva da 7 ore per
prendere anche i regali ai nipotini di
luigi lo so molto soddisfatto e abbiamo
trovato un javier ci devastato la 26 ma
perché sei qui non sfruttano francesi
sta comprando regali che andiamo a dare
fastidi a farci andiamo a fare pasti al
francese
allora devastante stato scusate sembrano
le undici di sera ma in realtà siamo
dentro al parcheggio i porti a roma
siamo devastati
io non auguro a nessuno una cosa così
perché veramente una cattiveria
io sto con la porta aperta adesso gli
direi di andare a prendere la linea
prendere otteniamo a fare la canzone che
eccoci qui e ora oggi guardiamo marco è
un processo è un processo credito perché
le aree linee dove lui stende sono come
le linee del pentagramma persona 5
perché non so se vedete che mancano
almeno serve un aiuto per l'occasione
anche richieda unicorno sì però il a
portare positività visto che sapevo che
la fine avrebbe comunque uno stato con
lui gli sguardi in tutto questo
d'ascolto capito
avevamo capito che abbiamo fatto un
errore molto grande al quale abbiamo
rimediato assolutamente segue portato
uno stuzzichino fantasma
ci sono altri sette birre in frigo e
l'ho dimenticato al supermercato era
buonissimo era cosa è più volevo ci
stiamo sfondando il candore mille cani
di terni
4 che non sono io sono vedere qualche
assaggio del pezzo
certo grado
[Musica]
a marzo ma gli ho sentito bene ok
facciamo lo facciamo tanto cioè voglio
dire non è che abbiamo una carriera che
siamo tutti nella stessa canzone
quest'anno abbiamo niente da perdere di
10 eur via ai ragazzi stiamo veramente
pc ci spreme chi ci sono nuove cose
tirar fuori dove fare una canzone molto
divertente in realtà non esser sincero
ma non facile dai 0 pensa pure quando tu
fai tutto questo lavoro e fa cagare
qualcuno certamente suscettibile prima
magari non c'è neanche tutto questo
lavoro quando fa così tagliare la
interessante è un punto di vista molto
interessante ti ringrazio leopardi
bene benissimo mare ma con alice vergani
ritoccato ogni volta che questo è una
preview ragazzi su quella che sarà la
canzone sappiate che non volevamo farlo
noi abbiamo deciso di farlo perché siamo
molto molto orgogliosi ma è un piccolo
assaggio
[Musica]
siamo qui da almeno sei ore
siamo molto soddisfatti non abbiamo
ancora finito ovviamente ma qual è la
birra però che si ma abbiamo tirato
fuori delle belle idee sempre avanti con
questo gran pezzo magari a questo punto
direi che ci vediamo domani
[Musica]